les études qui associe la consommation
de viande rouge aux risques de
développer certaines maladies se
comptent par dizaines
voilà qu'un groupe de chercheurs
indépendants vient brouiller les cartes
après l'analyse de plusieurs études
c'est ce qu'on appelle une méta analyse
il conclu que les preuves sont
incertaines pour moi s'ajoutent rien aux
des bols certifier le résultat est loin
de faire l'unanimité
ce cardiologue remettent en doute les
études sélectionnées par les experts
quand on regarde les autres ceux de
choisy b il ya un nom choisi qui était
moins bonne paye en ont éliminé qui
était très bas non c'est moi j'ai un
gros problème avec les méta analyse
publiée par l'american college of
physicians les résultats indiquent qu'en
réduisant à trois portions par semaine
notre consommation de viande rouge on
diminue les risques de mortalité par
cancer à 0,7 pour cent
un risque trop faible selon eux pourrait
être significatif les chercheurs disent
que c'est faible
mais cette sueur 1014 sur 2021 sur 3000
à l'échelle de la population
ça commence à faire des gens qui
pourraient être affectées le groupe de
chercheurs écorché au passage la façon
de mener les études en nutrition et
suggère de se baser sur le modèle
pharmaceutiques mais on peut pas faire
ça en nutrition double aveugle
ça veut dire que le médecin sait pas ce
que la personne pâques aux médicaments
et le patient sait pas si près placebo
ou non ou alors on peut pour faire 5 la
viande évidemment avec la nutrition la
personne c'est ce que mange
alors qui croire quand on sait que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
classe la viande rouge comme
cancérogènes probables et les
charcuteries comme cancérogènes on dit
aux gens de continuer à découvrir les
plaisirs de manger des aliments végétaux
oui de manger de la viande encore de
temps en temps si on aime sont vos potes
démoniser aucun aliment mais je pense
que ce que toujours été vrai c'est l'
équilibre
la société canadienne du cancer quant à
elle n'entend pas modifier ses
recommandations et c'est catherine
gauthier radio canada